et le mal km je vais te dire je suis
très inquiet parce que j'ai vraiment ton
portable qu'il m'appelle je vous raconte
l'histoire il ya un mec qui m'a envoyé
cyril répond moi je dois te dire un truc
de ouf la donc et un mec qu'a votre
portable c'est pas vrai halo qui est
large et pas un code n'est ce pas poster
mes chaussures mais ma parole
allô allô qui hélas ne retrouve pas je
déconne pas qui est là mais c'est qui
c'est qui ouais c'est un mec ya ton
ancien numéro 8 quand j'envoie des sms
en fait c'est lui qui me répond ouais
comment tu t'appelles gatien ouais c'est
pas tout à fait le même délire pas de
même débourser deux salles deux
ambiances et ben gassama je t'embrasse
mon chéri tu as quel âge 14 ans et a le
numéro jamel debbouze cette ruelle
vautrin est tu regardes touche pas à mon
poste là gatien salut gaza le gaza
l'auteur lui seul truc qui m'embête un
peu c'est que tu as mon âme soeur
[Rires]
c'est le seul délit relate me
ps ça l'agacé un méga c'est en tout cas
tu es au top à ce que tu m'a jamais
appelé en fait d'accord bon bah je
t'embrasse gatien votre ton petit-frère
0 tu sais que j'ai des cheveux qui
tombent tous les quarts d'heures
supplémentaires là toute la famille
rappelle moi tout à l'heure du luxe
j'embrasse sa du frérot
je commence donc l'acacia qui vous
embrasse voilà qu'à votre ancien numéro
alors mis je pense qu'il a regardé qui
ne doit pas regarder et qu elle souffre